I want to start right
where we left off,
which is in filling atoms,
filling electrons into atoms.
We've done a lot of work to know
what it is that we're filling.
We had to go all
the way to quantum
to know what orbitals
are, not just orbits.
Right.
And we talked about the
four quantum numbers, right?
And so now we're
going to use those,
and we're going to use the
exclusion principle from Pauli
and a few other things.
And we're going to fill
electrons into atoms.
So this is where we
left off on Monday.
There they are, right?
Remember, you know,
as I said on Monday,
if we only had Bohr, what we
would have is the left hand
side here, n equals 1.
We would have just have
n equals 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
but we wouldn't have any of
this variation of l, right,
like the p electrons,
the d electrons.
That differentiation
came in when
we solved the equations of
quantum mechanics, right,
for an electron in feeling
the potential of the proton.
And then the other
thing that happens
is these things don't
line up necessarily
exactly how you might
imagine, because there
are complicated effects, right?
It's not just a naive feeling.
Instead there's these
effects like shielding.
Right, so electrons all the
way out here in an atom,
they don't necessarily
see all the protons.
They're shielded.
And then to make matters
even more complicated,
these orbitals can wiggle
in with nodes, right?
This is what we did
Monday, with nodes
all the way in so they can
see-- some of these orbitals
have a little bit of them
that see the protons up close.
So we showed that with 2s.
That's called
orbital penetration.
And that's why these
things split up.
They have the same principle
quantum number, n is 2,
but this has a lower
energy than the 2p.
But how is the electron
moving within this orbital?
No.
It's not.
That's a classical way
of thinking, right?
And it's so hard to
stop thinking that way.
I know we want to
think that way.
But it's not.
An electron is being
in its orbital,
because an orbital is a
probability distribution.
All right?
So the electron, all we
know from that orbital
is that the electron has a
probability of being here
sometimes and a probability
of being there other times.
That's what it tells us.
So we know that in that
2s orbital, sometimes
it's really, really close
to those protons, right?
That was that orbital
penetration, the peak
that you saw on Monday.
All right, so with all
that knowledge just kind
of getting us back
in the mood here
and our quantum numbers
and our Pauli exclusion,
we're ready to fill.
And the way that
we're going to start
is the way that most chemistry
textbooks would start,
which is with a very
simple rule, all right,
called the aufbau principle.
And aufbau means-- so aufbau
means filling up in German.
And basically the idea
is that you fill--
you fill from the lowest
levels, the lowest.
Those are also the ground state.
Right, the ground state
would be the lowest, right?
That's the lowest energy, lowest
levels, ground state level,
energy, and up.
OK.
And you use what is
called the n plus l rule.
The n plus l rule means that
the ordering, the ordering
of the orbital energies--
orbital energies-- and let's
get a little more space here OK.
The ordering of the
orbital energies
increases with
increasing n plus l.
All right, you fill from
the lowest energy up.
So as my n plus
l, those are the--
remember, that's the shape.
This is sort of related to
the distance from the nucleus.
This is the principle
quantum number.
This is related to the
shape of the orbital.
Right l, and as that number
increases, the energy,
that's how you fill.
Oh, but there's the case
where it might be the same.
All right, so we have to
have another point here,
which is when two orbitals--
I did it again.
I forgot my r.
Two orbitals have the same
n plus l, then the lower n
has lower e.
OK, this is called
the n plus l rule,
but rules are made to be broken.
So as we're going to see, this
is actually really only true
maybe 80% of the time.
But we're going to use it,
because it is a good framework,
and it captures--
it gives us a way to start
thinking about electron
occupation and atoms.
And so if you take these
two points, this filling up
and the ordering of
how you fill things,
then you can draw this
as a very simple picture.
This is from the
textbook Averill,
right, where what you do
is you follow the arrows.
OK, so you go this arrow,
I'm filling 1s, this arrow,
then I go to 2s.
Right, it's not going anywhere.
So you go there, and
you keep following.
OK, so 2s, 2p, so you'd
fill 1s, 2s, then 2p, right,
because of the n plus
l rules is in effect.
And then, OK, 3s.
n is 3, l is 0.
That's n plus 2 is 3.
2p, 2p, n is 2, l
is 1, same value.
But now I go to this
one here, and when
they have the same value,
the lower n has lower energy.
Lower n filled first.
Filled first,
because the ordering
is to go from lowest energy up.
OK.
All right, so that's our
rule, which will be broken.
Now, how does this look?
Well, if we do this, we're going
to get a little notation here
and that's important,
if we do this,
and we just do a few atoms
here, so for hydrogen, right,
so for hydrogen we'd have--
that's the 1s orbital, and we're
putting in one electron in it.
Now, the notation
here is something
that we're going to use a lot.
So let me explain this.
This is n.
This is l.
That's the l in, what,
spectroscopic notation, right?
Remember we talked about
that Monday, right, s, p, d.
OK.
And then this is the
number of electrons.
And so if we keep going
with this notation,
then in the case of
helium, so for helium
you would have 1s2, because
I fill a second electron
into the 1s orbital.
Now, this is where
Pauli comes in.
Right, Paul said, OK, enough.
You're done with that orbital,
because I've got two electrons.
They do have different
quantum numbers.
They've got the same n.
Right, they've got the same l.
Their m sub l's are
the same because there
is no range here for s, right.
Remember m sub l for s can
only be, you know, zero.
But they have different
spins, up and down.
And so sometimes, what
is also really useful,
and we'll go back and forth
between these pictures,
is you go back to what we drew,
you know, with the Bohr model,
where we draw this in
terms of energy levels.
And so if you drew this
in terms of energy levels,
this is what'd you see.
So you'd have like energy.
And remember, in
the hydrogen atom,
this is minus 13.6
electron volts.
And so if you wanted to
draw this in this way,
you would say, OK, there
is one electron there,
and we'll-- remember, we said
you can draw electron spin with
arrows.
Right, whereas here, if we
drew this, then we draw--
I'm not putting
the energy there.
We don't know it, because Bohr
13.6 good for hydrogen. Right,
but here--
oh, and by the way, this
would be the 1s orbital.
This would be the 1s orbital.
But in this case, I've got two
electrons, one up, one down.
And now, Pauli says you're done.
All right.
And so if you go to lithium,
then you have 1s2 2s1.
And so if you drew this in
terms of an energy diagram,
you'd have the 1s, and
we're putting that,
and then you have the
2s somewhere up higher
where we put one electron.
Those are-- that's how you
would see these atoms in terms
of the filling of the
electrons into their orbitals.
Right.
OK, good.
Now, OK, let's keep going.
So what we'll do is
we'll do this here.
So let's see.
So beryllium would be 1s2 2s2.
And boron would be 1s2 2s2 2p1.
OK, this is looking
good here, right?
I'm really following aufbau now.
Oh, I went that way,
then I went that way,
and then I went up
here, and I started
on this arrow, which is just
a way, graphically, of showing
those rules.
Good.
Now, we get to carbon.
And now we have to
think about this, right,
because for carbon,
I've got 1s2 2s2 2p2.
That is correct.
All right.
But if I think about this
in terms of the energy,
1s2, 2s, right, well we
know from before, right, we
know from before, like 2p.
Where is 2p?
There it is.
It's got six electrons
that it can take.
Because now m sub l can vary
from minus 1, 0, plus 1.
Remember, that
corresponded to the three
different orientations
of the p orbital.
OK.
But that means that
I've got three,
so I can fill this
with 2, 2, and then
the question is, what do I do?
I don't know what to do.
Do I do this?
Is that right?
No, somebody says.
And that person knows
that the answer is no,
because that person knows Hund.
Where's Hund?
There he is.
Would have been more
dramatic had he appeared,
but there he is,
because Hund came up
with another rule, which
also is broken, sometimes.
Not as much as aufbau.
You know, so Hund said look,
when you have a case like this,
electrons in the same p, so the
same like orbital, sub shell.
OK, it's not the same sub
shell, but it's the same n 2p.
Let's draw that.
It is the same sub shell.
I'm saying opposite things.
2p, 2p.
Shell, sub shell.
But there are different
possibilities,
and how you fill them
according to Hund
is you maximize what's called
the multiplicity, which
means that you want
the electrons to come
in with the same spin
in different orbitals,
in different p orbitals.
That's how you fill them.
Why?
Well, that has to do with
more quantum mechanics,
and it has to do with something
called exchange energy that's
not part of what you
need to know about.
And I'm not going
to teach it here.
But you know, you can
think about it simply
as the electrons
want to spread out,
because they repel each
other in the same orbital.
Right.
They want a lot of
things, electrons.
They want to be
close to protons.
But they want to be kind
of not close to each other.
They need their space.
That's not a lot of things.
It's two things.
But that's what they want.
And this allows them to maximize
that and lower their energy.
And remember,
lowering your energy
means happiness for electrons.
So this is the preferred
way to fill, right?
And that's what
Hund's rule tells us.
Now, if you go to
silicon, and you say,
well, OK, what does
silicon look like?
All right, I'm going
to put silicon--
no, don't do that.
I'm going to put silicon
right underneath carbon,
because I think it's an
interesting comparison.
All right, so silicon is OK--
1s2 2s2 2p6.
They're all filled.
Right, and then you go
to 3s2 and you go to 3p2.
And this looks very
different than carbon,
but actually, you can
abbreviate the notation,
and we very often do in
these filling notation,
and we do it this way.
We say, well, this
has a neon core.
So you go to the
nearest noble gas,
not with more electrons,
because they're not there,
with less electrons.
You go to the nearest noble
gas, and say well, OK, that's
basically neon.
All right, this is neon.
And so you can write
the notation is this--
it's the same atom, just
a slightly abbreviated way
of writing it, where I
would write, OK, this is
a neon core with 3s2 and 3p2.
Well, you can write that
with a helium core, 2s2 2p2.
And what happens is you wind up
having a nice distinction here,
because these are
core electrons.
Remember, we're
filling electrons here.
That's electrons.
And these are called
valence electrons,
and we'll be talking
about valence chemistry
for the whole semester and what
these valence electrons do,
right?
And in fact, these
valence electrons,
these ones on the outside
closest to the out--
furthest away,
these are the ones
that have all of the
chemistry that we care
about in this class, chemistry.
It's so important
that I went all caps.
I'm not shouting,
but I went all caps.
Whereas the core electrons
are kind of mostly inert.
They're mostly inert,
chemically inert.
OK, and so sometimes
it's very useful
to write the notation
this way to see
what do you got in the
valence, what's going on?
Right, what does this valence--
because then you start
to see similarities.
The valence for lithium
and the valence for sodium
look really similar.
There's an outer s electron.
That's the quantum number,
the principle quantum number
is different.
But the valence
looks very similar,
one electron in an s orbital.
And that allows us
to think intuitively
about similarities
between elements,
because if they have
the same valence,
and the valence is responsible,
not same, but similar,
similar shapes of orbitals,
different principal
numbers, but if that's similar,
then maybe the chemistry
those elements do
is also similar.
This is a helpful way
to think about it.
OK.
I told you that rules
are meant to be broken,
especially when we're
talking about n plus l,
and it happens all the time.
And there's two main reasons
or important reasons,
and then there's a whole bunch
of other very complicated ones,
that two I want
you to know about,
which are exceptions
to this aufbau filling,
OK, which are
exceptions to that,
come in the
following situations.
That you get stability--
you get stability.
That means lower energy
for the whole system.
The system lowers
its energy and can
be more stable when either
an orbital is fully filled--
there it is, ns2, np6, nd10.
You know those are fully
filled, because that's
how many elections you can put
in each one, or half filled
exactly.
And so that's why in chromium
if you predict with aufbau,
you would get 4s2
3d4, but actually you
get 4s1 3d5, because you
can half fill both of those,
and that adds to the stability.
In copper, the predicted
one would be 4s2 3d9.
But actually what you see is
a fully filled d shell, which
adds to stability and
a half filled s shell.
So it's willing to
make this trade off
of a fully filled s
show for half filled.
That's not a big trade off
to get the d, fully filled.
OK, now there's more
complicated effects,
all sorts of effects that
also lead to violations
of the n plus l rule.
I really hesitate to call it
a rule, given that, you know,
there's a lot of
examples where it's not
about the half filling
or the full filling.
It's about complicated
interactions
that have to do sometimes,
all the way with things
like relativity, relativistic
effects, literally,
of these electrons, which will
not be on any quiz or exam,
with also the complexities that
happen with orbital penetration
as you add more
and more electrons
and the levels are kind
of closer together.
They're a lot harder to see
clearly separate energies
than in the first
two, three rows,
as you go down in
the periodic table,
those levels are closer
and closer together.
So anomalies happen.
But they're not really--
I'm not sure we should call
them anomalies, because these
are all exceptions to aufbau.
So like I said, I want
you to know aufbau,
because it's a
great way to start,
but I also want you to know that
sometimes things switch around
because of the effects that
we've been talking about.
I don't expect you to memorize
all the exceptions to aufbau,
OK?
But I do want you to know about
these two key factors, which
are half filling
and fully filling
leading to enhanced stability.
All right, good.
OK, so we got valence.
We got filling.
Now, right away, right
away, all right--
so by the way,
configurations are in here.
It's a beautiful thing.
When I look at this, I now
can look at this line in here
that shows--
that shows using this
notation, the filling
of electrons for every single
atom, every single atom.
And it's a beautiful thing
because it tells us so
much about the periodic table.
It tells us so much about
why the periodic table is
what it is.
It was arranged.
Right, it was arranged because
of things like the combination,
remember Mendeleev,
mass and properties.
But now we see why.
We see why.
It's incredible, because
it goes back to counting.
It literally goes
back to the quantum
mechanical derivations
of orbitals
and the principles
of filling them,
and then the filling
them themselves.
And you see, you know,
why does the lanthanides
and actinides, why did
those things run for 14?
Because that's
how many electrons
go into the f orbitals.
Right, that's how many
electrons go into 4f and 5f.
That's why these are 14.
Why are these two columns here?
Why do those have similar
properties as you go down?
Right, I mentioned
lithium and sodium, right.
Well, because of
what we just said.
You're increasing the
principle quantum number,
but the valence chemistry
is very similar.
They're all s.
And we even call
them sometimes these
blocks by the valence chemistry
that's getting filled.
Right, so those first two
columns are the s block.
Here over here,
they're the p block.
It's not that these don't
have p electrons in them.
It's that these are
the electrons that
are getting added in this part,
in this region, whereas here,
you've got d electrons.
And now we know
exactly why this is 10.
I mean, we know even more than
this, because aufbau says,
why is this here and not here?
Right, because of the
ordering of the filling,
of the energies of the filling.
These three d's come after 4s.
That's why they're here.
Right, that's why
they belong here.
We now know so much more.
We have so much more
insight into the ordering
of the periodic table,
because of electron filling.
And we'll be making
those connections.
We'll be making those
connections a lot.
Right, but I just wanted
to kind of show you
the power of seeing things
in terms of filling.
The one connection I'll
tell you about today
has to do with diameter.
OK, so we'll be
making connections
all throughout the class
between electron filling
and properties.
Right, but let's start with a
simple one, how big is an atom?
Well, now you can
understand some things.
Right, so for example, if I plot
here or if Averill plots it,
and I take that from
Averill and show it
to you, the probability--
remember we plotted
this before for 1s, 2s.
Now, what they plot
here, OK, the 1s orbital
for helium, that's got
two electrons in it.
There it is right
there, the 1s, and then
the 2s and 2p combined.
Right, everything is sort
of thrown together here.
They're not separated
for neon and then argon.
So these are the first three
noble gases, helium, neon,
argon.
OK.
And a couple of things.
One thing you can see is that
the s electrons in helium
are furthest out.
And then the neon ones are
closer in, and look at that.
The argon ones are even closer.
Why?
Why are the 1s electrons
getting closer in
as I add more electrons?
Right.
Well, it has to do with
what we talked about Monday.
Those 1s electrons
are not screened.
So what they see as you go
from helium to neon to argon
is more and more
positive charge.
In fact, I've got
the numbers here,
if you look at the
1s electron energy,
remember for hydrogen, 13.6.
Now remember, I didn't
write a value there.
But there's two protons.
So that 1s electron for helium.
So if we take 1s electron
energy, so much abbreviation.
For helium, it's 24.5 eV.
That's how much it would take.
So we can put minus, if you
want to compare with this,
right, this minus 13.6.
That's also how
much it would take
to ionize that 1s electron.
That's where it sits.
But if you look at neon,
neon is minus 869.5 eV.
And argon is minus 3,206 eV.
That is a lot of energy.
That is a lot more energy.
That is much, much happier.
If energy-- if lower
energy is happiness,
those 1s electrons
are super happy,
and they get closer to
all that positive charge.
But you can also understand
why, like neon is larger
than helium, and argon, even
though these energies of the 1s
are closer and closer,
these are still
going to be larger, because
as you go down in a column,
you add a whole shell.
Right, so I can't--
right, so remember,
here's my plus charge.
Here's my minus charge.
I can't-- this is 1s.
Now I can't add
anything in here.
I got to add stuff
out here and go out.
Remember those principle
quantum numbers, 1 to 2?
Right, we don't need the
s here, just 1 to 2 to 3,
they're going to push you
further and further out.
We talked about that Monday.
So now the next
electrons that come
in in neon's case in 2s or 2p
or in argon's case, 3s and 3p,
those are going to
come much further out.
That's why when you look
at size, which is what's
shown here, you see this trend.
All right.
So you see this trend that
as you go down a column, here
they are.
Here they are.
So this is the size
in the periodic table,
and these are calculated.
These are calculated.
Why are they calculated?
Because you can see, this should
be pretty hard to measure.
Right, these are hard to
measure unless the atoms are
in like a solid, and
they're bonded together.
So measured atomic
radii are often
taking half of a bond length.
But we can also calculate them.
And that's why these are
calculated atomic radii.
So these have no bonding.
They're just isolated,
and they're calculated
and there's helium,
neon, and argon.
OK, fine.
So we just understood that.
And we understood this
arrow that the radii
get larger as you go
down the periodic table.
But what about going across?
Why?
I'm adding stuff to the atom.
I'm filling lithium here.
I'm adding an electron and from
lithium there to beryllium.
How can it get smaller?
Right.
So that has to do--
what did I do?
OK, I'm going over here.
All right.
So that has to do
with the fact--
with the same things that
we've been talking about.
It has to do with the fact
that as I go from lithium.
So OK, let's do this.
If I have hydrogen,
and I go to lithium,
you know that it's
going to be larger
for the reasons I just said.
But if I go from lithium over
to beryllium, it gets smaller.
And the reason is
because of exactly this.
If I go from hydrogen to
lithium, I add protons.
But I shield those
protons with electrons.
OK, but if I am at lithium,
let's see, lithium is here.
So I've got one, two, three.
And I've got an electron here.
Right, I've got two
electrons in the 1s orbital,
and then I've got one
electron in the 2s orbital.
OK, so that's lithium.
But now I go to beryllium.
And if I'm beryllium,
I've got four.
OK, and so now I've got
those 2s electrons here.
But see-- I'm sorry, 1s.
But in the 2s orbital, I
can put a second electron.
Right, and so what happens
is those two electrons
in the 2s orbital, they don't
really screen each other.
They are screened
by the 1s orbital.
So if I now--
because I went-- even
though I added an electron,
I also have a lot
more charge here.
Right, and because these
two don't screen each other,
but these two do, right, these
are going to be closer in,
because they're more attracted.
They're only screened
by these two electrons.
So the additional
positive charge wins.
If I go down in
quantum number, then I
get a whole shelf
filled to screen.
But here, I'm just
adding another electron
to the same orbital
to the 2s orbital.
But I've got a hold other
proton, and the shielding,
the screening is the same.
That's why beryllium is
smaller than lithium,
even though you've
added an electron.
And it's why the trend goes
like this, increasing that way,
decreasing that way.
Now, I like dancing.
And so I like this
dancing analogy,
because I love thinking
about atoms as dancing.
I told you about the disco
and the periodic table.
But you can take that
all the way to the atom.
So you know, you can imagine
that you're an electron,
and you see a proton.
OK, so dance pairs are happy.
Dancers are happy if they have
more people to dance with.
And so if I'm hydrogen,
and I'm an electron,
and I see a proton, protons
can only dance with electrons.
And then I say, OK, let's dance.
And you kind of start moving,
you know, a little bit.
And but now, I'm
going to go to helium.
So there's another
dancer in the middle,
and someone comes on, and says,
oh OK, that's cool, right.
I can--
Now, either one of us can
dance with either one of those.
All right, so I've got
two different people.
I'm happier closer in.
We can get close,
because there's choices
for who you can dance with.
All right.
So that's why you get helium
much smaller than hydrogen.
More people to dance with.
Now you're lithium,
and you come along,
and I'm a lithium
electron here, and I'm
like I want to
dance with somebody.
Who's there?
And there's only one person,
because these two people
are totally occupied.
I only have one
possibility for people
to dance with if I'm
this lithium electron.
Right, but now I come in, and
I'm beryllium, and these two
electrons, and
they're both like,
well, OK, you guys are
blocking, whatever.
That's not cool.
But there's four
people in the middle.
So there's always two
or three people, right,
that we can dance with.
That wasn't like a move.
I don't know what that was.
But I'm like I can dance with
you or I can dance with you.
And more dancing
choices, happier.
Happier, lower energy.
So that's how I
like to see atoms.
OK, so that's one example
of filling and screening
and dancing, where this kind
of picture of the atoms,
this electron filling of the
orbitals explains what we see.
OK, now, we talked
about ionization,
and we talked about how
sometimes those outer electrons
can be lost, or sometimes,
maybe an atom would
gain an outer electron.
If an electron is lost from
an atom, called an ion.
And so a charged atom
is an ion, and a cation
is a positive charge,
positive charge.
Abbreviations.
Right, and so here's
sodium, and it's
got all those dancers in there,
and it has lost an electron.
There it is.
It's going to lose--
remember we talked about the
first ionization potential.
We talked about that last week.
It's going to lose that lowest--
sorry, the highest
energy electron,
the least bound
electron, the one that's
all the way out there.
And so if it does, it's NA plus.
OK, gesundheit.
Now, you can also--
this is from Averill.
You can also lose
more than that.
All right, magnesium
might lose two electrons.
So the gray part
here is the ion,
and the blue part is the
original neutral atom,
all right.
And you can see that if
sodium loses one electron,
and magnesium loses
two, those actually
have the same
number of electrons.
They're different atoms.
Those are called isoelectronic.
Well, you can also
gain electrons.
So if you write that down.
So you know, if
you gain electrons,
does anybody know
what those are called?
Anion, OK, negative charge
would be in an anion.
OK, and I can ask question.
If I lose an electron, it
makes sense that I got smaller.
This is the radius.
And if I gain, it make
sense that I got bigger.
And I can mix it up.
So I could ask you a question,
like what's the ordering--
what's the ordering
of these atoms.
Right, I could say, well, if
I had Mg 2 plus and Ca 2 plus,
and Ca, what's the
ordering of their size?
You now know how to answer
questions like this, right?
If I lose electrons, I'm
going to get smaller.
If I gain electrons,
I'm going to get bigger.
But I also know that
for example, Ca 2 plus
is smaller than Ca, and
Ca is bigger than Mg.
Right.
And so Ca 2 plus is going
to be bigger than Mg 2 plus.
Right, that makes
a lot of sense.
Done.
You can order them now.
All right, so Ca must be
bigger than Ca 2 plus,
and that must be
bigger than Mg 2 plus.
So we can think about now
adding in ions to the mix.
And we're doing
this for a reason.
All right, we're doing
But because, you see, some atoms
really don't mind doing this.
They really don't.
Sodium is one of them.
They don't mind losing atoms.
I mean, yeah, the
electron is there.
But it's kind of there as
sort of like, I could be here,
I can be there.
I'm good.
Whereas those 1s
electrons, you know
the 1s electrons are
argon, are like you just
try to take me out.
All right, no way.
But we will.
We will ionize those next week.
But for now, we're taking
these outer ones out
that may not be
strongly balanced.
They're happy,
losing or gaining.
And how do you know?
How do you know?
If you have ions, how
do you know, you know,
whether you have them?
Well, here's the
deal, you now know
a way to tell because in
this goodie bag, which I'll
talk about in a few
minutes, you actually
have the most accurate
measuring device ever made.
You have a scale.
That's not-- no.
It's in here somewhere.
You have a conductivity
meter, somewhere in here,
which I cannot find.
And the conductivity
meter is exactly that.
There it is.
Oh, look at this.
This is incredible.
So you can put this
into a solution,
and it literally
just measures-- it's
got two electrodes
that go in there,
and it measures whether
there's any conduction,
and you can see, well,
if I've got charge
species in the solution,
ions, then this will tell you,
because they'll help
conduct electricity.
So you now have a way of knowing
when you have ions or not.
OK, so that's good.
But you see, the thing is
something very important
happens when atoms
come together--
when atoms-- don't
measure anything yet.
But take it to lunch.
Take it to lunch.
You don't know.
People talk about electrolytes.
They talk a big game.
All right.
Now, the thing is when
atoms react, when--
this sounds like the
beginning of a novel.
When atoms react,
right, sometimes they
will gain or lose.
When atoms react, they
may want to gain or lose
the amount of electrons to get
them to the closest noble gas.
OK, closest noble gas.
Now, that's really important.
We just talked about how
you use the noble gas
notation-- did I just erase it?
I did.
Because that could
be chemically inert.
And we can only go down
when we do the notation,
but now we can go up,
because I could add electrons
to get to the nearest noble
gas, in terms of reacting.
And look at this.
If sodium is an atom that
doesn't mind losing electrons
and chlorine is an atom that
really wants to gain electrons,
and they come together,
then you can form a bond.
Oh, oh boy.
Here we are I guaranteed you.
I told you on Monday,
we would get here.
I said, it's our three
week anniversary,
and I think we're going to bond.
First bond, first bond.
And it's ionic.
It's ionic.
Because this is a bond of
an electrostatic attraction.
This is the bond of
electrostatic attraction
between two oppositely
charged atoms.
So between two
oppositely charged atoms.
And so if I've got a
positive and a negative,
they're going to be attracted.
How are they going
to be attracted?
Well, actually
that's an attraction
that we know all about.
Oh there it is.
Hold up.
We just made our first bond.
Let's talk about it.
What do I want to say?
I want to talk about
that attraction.
Because that's
actually attraction
that we know very well.
It's a Coulomb attraction.
Right, and so the
way this works is
if I'm an atom with
positive charge,
and I'm an atom with
negative charge.
All right, so let's
take that same example,
and this is the energy.
And this is say, zero.
And this is the distance
between the two atoms.
If I'm out here, then
maybe the distance
between sodium and
chlorine is very far.
But you see there's
a Coulomb attraction.
And so the attraction
is Coulomb,
which is going to be
minus a constant times
the charges on those ions over
the distance between them.
All right.
So that-- if I draw
that attraction,
this is the charges on
ions, charges on ions.
And if I draw that, the Coulomb
attraction looks like this.
That's it.
Right, that's 1 over r.
But see, the thing is
if they get too close,
then those core, you know,
then things start to repel.
It's like, whoa, whoa.
Hold on.
I'm not going to go
any further, because I
don't like having the same
charges getting too close,
right.
I don't like that.
Your electrons are getting
too close to my electrons,
and don't make me go nuclear.
And so what you get is you
get something like this.
And this would be the potential
energy of those two ions.
They can't get
super duper close.
But when they're far away,
they're kind of free, and then
as they get a
little closer, they
start feeling that attraction,
that Coulomb attraction.
And this energy here,
this energy has a name.
It's called the lattice energy,
because for the solid, right?
So if I make a solid out
of these types of ions,
and now I break it all up,
and I go all the way out
to just loan ion, so
I go from the isolated
ions to a solid of these ionic
bonds, then I gain this energy.
And it takes that energy
to break them back up.
That's called the
lattice energy.
And you can see
right away, there
are some really kind of
interesting observations
you can make related to
this simple relationship
of a Coulomb attraction
for an ionic bond.
All right, so here's
two ionic solids.
There's sodium chloride.
There's magnesium oxide.
There's Na plus and F minus.
OK, and notice the
Coulomb energy here.
And notice the differences
in the lattice energy.
This is like four times that.
That is exactly what you get
from this, because in this case
Q1 and Q2 are both 1,
right, 1 and negative 1.
And here, Q1 and Q2 are
both 2, and negative 2.
So it should be four times,
and that's, in fact, you
can measure how much energy does
it take to break this thing up,
four times as much.
That's the lattice energy.
So we know something about this.
And you can see trends.
Right, so these
are now the radii.
We just talked about these.
Right, radii for ions.
And this is the lattice energy.
And you can see that if I'm the
smallest one, and the smallest
one there, I have the
highest lattice energy.
And that's the 1 over r part.
So you got the charge and
how close they can get.
And you now know from-- just
from the trends we've just
talked about, the radii
trends we just talked about,
you know how you might compare
how much one ionic solid
is bonded, compared to
another, because you
can talk about how much
charge it might lose or gain.
It likes to get close to
the nearest noble gas.
And you can also think about
their size or relative sizes.
So like the largest
one with the largest
has a larger r, and so
weaker lattice energy.
And boy, is this important.
It changes all sorts of
things about the properties
of these solids, and that's
why, we developed the goodie bag
to help you explore that.
So you have different solids.
They're not all
ionic, because you're
talking about another
kind of solid next week.
Right, but you've got
some ionic solids.
And look, like, you
know, so a lot of them
dissolve, but if the
lattice energy is so high,
maybe it doesn't dissolve.
Or maybe it's
harder to dissolve.
How do you know?
Well, you could see
it if you stir it.
All right.
But you also may
be able to measure.
Are there ions in solution?
If there are ions
in solution, than it
could be a dissolved ionic
solid that you've made.
And so-- oh hardness,
Mohs' scale.
You can look that up.
Did something scratch
something else?
Right.
That's what that's related to.
Melting point,
right, the properties
depend on this ionic bond.
OK so there's the goodie
bag, and then I'll
do my why this matters in
the last couple of minutes
of class.
All right, so there's
the goodie bag.
Oh, you've got a
conductivity meter.
You've got a scale.
I used to give that scale
out with white powder right
before Thanksgiving for
a different goodie bag,
and it was a really bad idea.
But now it was--
it was citric acid, lime juice.
But people traveled like that.
And so we've learned.
We've learned.
And so we give it to you
now, but please keep it.
It's the world's
most accurate scale.
Why does this matter?
Because look-- you're going
to need the scale again.
So please keep it.
Here you go.
Here's another chart
of ionic bonds.
These are lattice energies.
OK, these are lattice energies,
oh kilojoules per mole,
it's just per mole of stuff.
Right, don't get
confused by that.
Joules, electron volts,
energies, per mole
is per mole of atoms, right?
OK, so we can isolate it down
to one bond or a mole of bonds.
All right, 15,000 for aluminum.
Look at that.
That's why aluminum
is in your toothpaste.
Aluminum oxide is
in your toothpaste.
It's in your pans.
It's in sandpaper.
It is a very hard material.
Why?
Because of this.
Literally.
Those Q's are
really high, right?
Why does this matter?
Well, I'm going to give you
an example in hemodialysis.
Hemodialysis is
something that people
have to go into a hospital.
People in their kidneys, don't
clean their blood efficiently
or enough have to have
it cleaned by a machine,
and 650,000 patients
suffer from this
and go to a hospital
for literally four
hours, three times a week.
It devastates their
weekly schedule.
And if you could
make this portable,
you would change lives
in a really big way.
One of the big--
there are people out
there trying to do this.
This is an example of a design
for a portable hemodialysis
machine.
One of the single biggest
drawbacks in making it portable
is making a filter, because
you're filtering blood.
You're filtering toxins
out of the blood.
It's something that
the body can't do.
So you need to do it for them.
But the filters get
mucked up and gunked up,
and they're not strong enough,
and they can't be cleaned.
And look at this one.
Here is a filter
made out of aluminum.
All right, and these
things are what's needed.
We need super strong,
super resilient new filters
that can filter
things like blood
and toxins out of the blood.
So very, very tiny sizes
that we can make over
large areas and uniformly.
This is the kind of
starting material
that we need to
make new filters,
and it all comes back down.
Why would that be
a good one if we
can overcome it's brittleness?
Because of the Q's.
Because of the atom sizes,
because of everything
that we talked about today.
So have a great long weekend,
and see you guys next week.